[Music]
Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy is a 2011 spy
thriller starring Gary Oldman Tom Hardy
Benedict Cumberbatch mark Strong and
Colin Firth the cerebral conspiracy
centers around British intelligence
investigating mole within their ranks
due to its nonlinear plot and subtle
ending it may leave some viewers
scratching their heads throughout this
video I will be discussing the key
aspects of the film as well as what it's
ending signifies this is a classic film
so I highly recommend that you go and
check it out if you haven't already
obviously there will be key spoilers
here and it's definitely worth your time
with that out the way and definition and
this is my ending explained video for
Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy in order to
understand the movie we must first
structure it in chronological order the
plot element that initiates the entire
film involves Gary Oldman's character
smiley attempting to get the Russian
agent Carla to defect from his country
Sheeran now meetin smiley discusses his
wife and gives the Russian agent lighter
that he received as a present from her
Carla does not defect and instead uses
this meeting to come to the realization
that smiley and his wife's relationship
is very fragile
the next key event is the Christmas
party here the double agent Bill Hayden
played by Colin Firth is tasked with
destroying Smiley's relationship and he
begins an affair with the character's
wife his assumed lover and good friend
Jim played by Mark Strong notices the
affair and comes to the realization that
pill is only participating in the act
because he has been given a mission and
is therefore a double agent
witchcraft is then set up by Al Elaine
this involves the safehouse in which a
Russian mole gives agents intelligence
on the KGB however in the film we
discover that the apparent Russian
double agent is in fact a triple agent
and that he is only supplying Britain
with low-level intelligence and using
this as a meeting point in which to gain
in-depth knowledge on the British Secret
Service from Bill Hayden Ricki Tarr
uncovers this when investigating the
Russian agent and begins having an
affair with his wife someone who is
later killed during an interrogation
that follows the next plot point
Jim is tasked with travelling to
Budapest in order to find out the
identity of the mole however the mission
is a cell
Jim is shot captured and interrogated
Karla believes that he is the agent
having an affair with the Russian spies
wife however when he doesn't flinch upon
seeing her executed they realized that
they are mistaken the mission going sour
forces control and smiley to resign and
Bill's cover is safe because of the
affair that he was having that allowed
him to be aware of the mission bill
manages to get Jim released and the
character returns to England where he is
forced to play dead and take a new
career path Ricki Tarr returns to
England and after reaching out to Oliver
about the mole smiley is reinstated
during his investigation he discovers
that Jim is still alive and after
finding Ricki Tarr comes to the
realization that there is definitely a
mole within the organization smiley
sends Todd to Paris in order to send a
message that will entrap the mole and at
the safe house set up by witchcraft he
confronts him it is revealed that killed
deliberately broke down Smiley's
marriage as part of the mission and the
character is murdered by Jim in the
final C we watch as a tear rolls down
both of their cheeks one of Blood and
the other
we can assume that the two were in a
relationship due to comments made by Jim
upon discovering that one of his
students was called Bill and by the fact
that bill asks for some money to be
given to a boy upon his capture this
could potentially be his lover however
due to the double-sided nature of spying
we may never know for sure
Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy is an
incredible film and it's one that took
me a while to get around to if you
haven't watched it for a couple of years
then I highly recommend that you go back
and revisit it
there are several subtle moments and the
movie relies on drama rather than
full-blown action set-pieces to deliver
unrivaled tension I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film and if you think
I've missed out anything please comment
below and let me know if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and
subscribe to my channel as I do ending
explain discussions across a wide range
of media and there will definitely be
something on the channel that you love I
recently covered the ending of God of
War and infinity walk which are left at
the end of this video so make sure you
check them out thanks again for taking
the time to watch this I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]